we never got discouraged we killed five
we kept pushing we kept encouraging and
that's the biggest part about that that
this locking everyone you know is always
fighting to the end regardless of what
the score is saying we kind of don't
even look at the scoreboard we uh you
know play 60 minutes and we play every
play and then that towards the end of
the game that's when we kind of look at
the scoreboard and see what was going on
yeah I thought that like Michael was
affecting the team and the success of
the offense I would for sure move on but
at the same time I feel like I'm still
moving around I'm still able to run
scramble throw and I mean we just we
just have a nice cute high enough high
enough success rate as offense Patrick
Roy Holmes with both legs wrapped
together is a better option than Matt
Moore
so Patrick please please you're not
being selfish you're just being
realistic
Patrick mahomes playing on his knees is
better than Matt Moore on his two feet
so they're sticking with Patrick mahomes
but yeah clearly is a different guy when
he's hobbled yeah they badly need their
bye week so he can get healthy yeah the
problem is it's five games away for the
Chiefs right and look they were four I
know we're ready to put them in the AFC
Championship game against the Patriots
the only question is when they play on
December 8 who wins that game so
therefore who has home-field advantage
now the Chiefs have lost two in a row at
home right
what's wrong with the Chiefs well I
think it's it's fairly obvious I mean
yes you're right about my homes and then
it gets you know just it accentuated to
a bigger you know a bigger problem when
your offensive line can't pass protect
right now you know I think that's really
one of the biggest issues and of course
that starts with let the left tackle
issue they have but they've been
steamrolled in that department you know
they're not a team that's gonna alert us
try to kiss stay consistent with the run
game and then you know the same old
story it's just the defense can't get a
stop when you when they need it it just
you never have any faith did you ever at
one at any point yesterday doubt that
deshaun Watson wasn't gonna make the
plays when he needed to to drive the
ball down the field or convert a third
down or a fourth down I mean that's what
I worry about the Chiefs are just not
enough difference makers and they
obviously are a little bit in trouble
but not in the AFC you know they still
have time to work
work it out and wiggle their way out of
it to get out of this funk but remember
when we said that the Chiefs defense
doesn't have to be much better this year
yeah no way it's can be worse right is
it worse than it was last year
I don't think it's worse I think one of
the big issues more than anything I
don't know maybe it is worse
okay the sooner these numbers yeah go
ahead go ahead
the Chiefs have given up at least 180
rushing yards in four straight games
that's Ravens had 203 Lions had 188
Colts had 180 Texans had 190 oh man yeah
that's that's not good because the big
thing is and this is something I talked
about in my podcast a little bit they
gotta change their approach they gotta
take something away they don't take the
running game away pass game away you
know then you're gonna put their eggs
into one basket but you know no Chris
Jones yesterday that's their best
defensive player Frank Clark's been good
but nothing great okay and then you get
through the rest of their defensive line
and you start naming names and guys and
years ago yeah linebackers huh okay
secondary huh yeah they got take a honey
badger yes but everybody do it by
himself no we can't do it by himself so
you know again there's right now without
a Chris Jones there's no difference
maker or guy that makes a play on a big
third down to get them off the field and
that's an issue for their team right now
because teams are keeping their offense
on the sidelines if they could get Jalen
Ramsey yeah assuming that Jaguars have a
change of heart he was gonna play
yesterday shot Khan the owner of the
team is very optimistic about it and
ultimately he's inactive again yeah
decided to trade him does he make a
difference in Kansas I do think he does
make a difference yes I think a guy like
Steve Spagnola would know how to use him
now I don't think they're gonna go from
like you know whatever they're ranked
defensively in the NFL which I'm not
even sure what they are and I got a look
now because we're sitting here and doing
this
but either way no I think the one thing
that you know he would make a difference
more than anything is okay you take the
best receiver now we can crowd the line
of scrimmage to stop the run or stop a
DeAndre Hopkins or somebody like that on
a big third down cuz we'll put a bunch
of people over there or Jalen Ramsey on
it the big thing I've heard that they
were really in the conversation for
Jalen Ramsey in that trade but you're
gonna have to pay Jalen Ramsey to be the
highest-paid corner in the history of
football and then we
that they're gonna have to pay the
quarterback the same thing and I'm not
so sure that's a formula that's gonna be
good for the rest of the football team
going forward I wonder if this
experience as Patrick mahomes closes in
on becoming eligible for his second
contract but I have argued in the past
that when that window opens after week
17 not after the playoffs after week 17
he should say I want what I am do now
yeah does it make him softer does it
make him write more like Tom Brady
there's that scale from Peyton Manning
to Tom Brady where Peyton Manning was
grabbed every less penny you can write
Tom Brady was do a below-market deal
yeah where does he land on that and and
maybe when he looks right on the roster
he says hey maybe I should take I think
he could be Brady ish where I mean again
is it gonna make a difference in his
life when he gets done and he's got 250
million in the bank compared to 230
million and he's making a lot off - yeah
- they got it they gotta get him on the
field superlatives next it's right here
you
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports